[Applause]
all right
this water is so good happy Tuesday you
lovely people of America
so did you see the latest video by
Donald Trump he's running for president
don't you know
some supporters here
and he's wasting no time proposing a
list of things to make America great
again so what's his bold National vision
for America how about brand new cities
on government land and with the
objective be a Quantum Leap in the
American standard of living
our objective will be a Quantum Leap in
the American standard of living almost
one-third of the land mass of the United
States is owned by the federal
government we should hold a contest to
Charter up to 10 new cities and award
them to the best proposals for
development a new shot at home ownership
and in fact the American dream you want
bold that's bold as bold is using hot
sauce to treat herpes foreign
that's not a suggestion some people
learn the hard way we keep hearing about
affordable housing but no one really
ever has a handle on it and that's
because our cities aren't built for
adding that to the mix cities are now
for the elites and their therapists so
it's time for New Towns planned wisely
from the ground up and one town could
also be a solution for the homeless by
choice sure you could live off the land
but not on my front lawn you can't crap
in front of my kids or piss in my flower
bed only I can do that
so you want to live a rent-free bill
free drug-fueled existence maybe there's
a new city for that one with medical
help food intents after all why should
those perks only be for illegal
immigrants
but they'd live separately with
civilized society nearby in case these
folks decided to stop being a Democrat
so who can argue against this well since
Trump thought of it probably everyone in
the media he also talked about an idea
that Ted Kennedy was way ahead on flying
cars
[Laughter]
you know
I bet there are dozens of major
companies in the United States and China
racing to develop vertical takeoff and
Landing vehicles for families and
individuals
dozens of major companies in the United
States and China are racing to develop
vertical takeoff and Landing vehicles
for families and individuals just as the
United States led the automotive
revolution in the last century I want to
ensure that America not China leads this
revolution in air Mobility
my China
talk about forward-looking while
Democrats look at the past and tell us
everything we've done is evil Trump is
saying look ahead we can do anything
we're not The Flintstones We're The
Jetsons that was an animated TV show
about a space age family cat
it had a robot housekeeper they had a
robot housekeeper named Rosie she wears
a maid's hat and an apron and a dress
talk about a bright future even the
robots knew housework is women's work
terrible
Trump also wants to revitalize rural
industries that makes sense
globalization traded farming and
Manufacturing in small towns for cheap
socks at Walmart made by our enemies we
can't pull ourselves up by our
bootstraps when they're cheap Chinese
bootstraps
our strategic national manufacturing
initiative which is going to be very big
and very very successful we will turn
forgotten communities into hives of
Industry
producing the goods we will no longer
import from China I gotta hand it to
them when it came to getting the beat on
China he was first and he was almost
always alone that's a pretty big thing
to get right especially when all his
naysayers got it wrong he's like the one
guy who said you know that Hindenburg
doesn't look safe I'll take a taxi
now here's my favorite proposal of all
he wants to launch a baby boom with
bonuses for young parents after all we
can't leave it all to Elon Musk and Pete
exeth
we'll ask Congress to support baby
bonuses for young parents to help launch
a new baby boom
what a great idea I can see it now
Red Hats but instead of Maga
it says mafa
[Laughter]
make America
frisky again
you didn't think I was going to be that
blunt but how about make America make
Americans again if that's not a winner I
don't know what is you'll lock up the
husband vote at a minimum and if not you
can sell the hats to bachelorette
parties
then there's Trump's last thing make
things beautiful
finally I'll challenge the governors of
all 50 states to join me in a great
modernization and beautification
campaign getting rid of ugly buildings
getting rid of
ugly buildings
that's the best of course the guys into
real estate he knows ugly buildings suck
I think that was the quote under his
high school yearbook picture and let's
face it most cities already look like
they've done most of the demolition work
already I mean we could just hire antifa
to do the rest
so here's what we got we got new
inexpensive practical cities built on
available government land we have flying
cars yippee you also got repopulation in
beautiful buildings so all this really
boils down to optimism on meth which is
the best kind of optimism there is so
it's clear he's running for president
and I'm sorry media never trumpers and
skittish Republicans you didn't think he
was going to let you get away unscathed
did you so wake up and get ready the
ride's about to get bumpy because for
Trump it's all about the future and he's
going to be in it whether you want him
to or not
welcome tonight yes
he looks like he jumped off the roof
with an umbrella as a child Fox News
contributor Tom salou
her opinions are so strong they come
with a warning label host of Sunny's
corner on SiriusXM Patriot Sonny Johnson
the only time he brings down the house
is with the help of termites Rider and
comedian Joe DeVito
finally she's on the FBI's Least Wanted
list Fox News contributor
[Applause]
Tom how you doing pretty good Greg so
what do you make of this whole package
it does seem like he's targeting the
lost American dream like you want
affordable housing you want to have a
family that kind of thing yeah he's
going big I don't know if I like the
first two the new I've never thought oh
we need more new cities in this country
yeah uh maybe I I would like to see
revitalizing the cities that have uh
gone downhill uh that's impossible
though because they're run by liberals I
know that so do you see I think these
new ones would be too though Craig I
don't know if no no no no they would be
run by me
think about it think about it you can't
fix cities that don't want to be fixed
so the only thing you can do is leave
and start new ones which is kind of what
he's talking about but continue I think
so let's get to what I like I like the
revitalizing the manufacturing sector
that's where his strengths are of course
I like the Trump 1.0 build the wall I
actually liked buying Greenland that was
one from the last yes go ahead and buy
Greenland I like that but the
revitalizing the manufacturing sector
and the uh the families thing is great
bonuses for people to have kids a new
baby boom that is a great big idea
something they're doing in Hungary uh
encouraging people to procreate and I so
I think that's a great idea so do you
have to do with your wife what's that
yeah I mean I get it but I mean it'd be
really cool if it was like it has to but
stipulation it has to be somebody you
don't know no no that's no that's not
that would be cool well I'm saying no of
course it would be an agreement it's all
the pool of people signing you see my
point no
[Laughter]
you have to volunteer is what I'm
getting at so you like that idea yeah I
like that idea and I think it's I don't
know if I could retroactively you know I
mean I've already had kids could I go
collect on them uh after it's like the
loan forgiveness plan yeah it's like
we're gonna give you pay you back if you
paid your debt already they're still
gonna give you a refund exactly and I
like the beautification it's something
people don't think a lot about and you
know we got it got a laugh when he said
he wants to tear down ugly buildings but
making cities and the country more
beautiful is something that no one
really talks about and it should happen
he's talking about things as a is it is
it is it looking really looking forward
or is it looking back to the good old
days was there anything here Sunny that
said oh I could get on with that I mean
this is a this is going to be a hellish
campaign correct no I'm thinking um I'm
in Petty signimo right now yeah because
this is literally what I told the
the Trump campaign in 2016. this is like
the literal advice that I gave to the
Trump campaign in 2016. and we got what
the hell you have to lose instead of hey
let's rebuild the cities hey whose name
is going to be on the building next to
Trump Towers come on Black America let's
build let's grow like I literally was
like this is how you do it you go in
this is what would win you it's the same
thing that would win us why don't you do
this and instead we got what in the hell
do you have to lose so I'm feeling more
Petty than I'm feeling hot
um but but to go to what you said about
the Jetsons because I used to love the
Jetsons right you used to watch it all
the time and we would always wonder
where the food came from right so how do
you just magically make a hamburger
Peter I like all of this right and so we
were like you know one day in the future
we're gonna have this event because we
thought it was making actual food right
we didn't realize it was going to be
paste and byproducts made to look like
food and now we're seeing with the fake
meat and everything else when the
machines come that actually make our
food it's not going to be real food it's
going to be gel turned into a food-like
product so that ruined my whole um way
that I look at the Jetsons but lastly
um this is not
a good plan because this is a leftist
plan they are making what they call the
10 minute 15-minute cities the purpose
of these cities is that everything is in
a is in a 15-minute walking distance so
you don't have to have a car they can
keep you in a limited area you don't go
and travel you're not wasting energy it
helps you cut down on your on your
carbon um footprint so it is not meant
as a oh let's do this and beautify and
and bring in new no it is a green deal
initiative made to cut down on energy
and stop humans from having the ability
to move freely across um spaces I didn't
see that angle Joe I thought it was to
get people yeah who may not have
families who are living alone they're
already about other people they're
already building them in Saudi Arabia
and other countries there are 10
15-minute cities everything in the city
15 minutes in walking distance no cars
well as I've always said good enough for
Saudi Arabia good enough for me
you have always said that you haven't
said that I'll tell you this about Trump
he's the only ex-president who looks the
same as he did when he left yeah coming
into office and leaving the rest of them
all come out looking like Moses after he
came down
so I guess he's he I guess uh orange
don't crack I don't know
I could believe the plans that they we
could just go into this undeveloped
areas and I think what we need to do is
take the cities that have failed and
turn them into gated communities uh but
the lock is on the outside right so they
have to live with it I don't think we'll
get the uh the flying cars uh for the
same reason we don't have the jet packs
we're too fat yeah we can't get the lift
off we need and I I hope we could beat
China with some sort of technological
innovation but keep in mind they just
invaded us with balloons yeah so that
was not too impressive that is true that
is true basically like a flying car cat
is it's just a drone with a stronger
battery but what happens if you like run
out of battery power then you just fall
to your death I don't think that's a
good way to go I don't either thank you
Tom I also don't want to fall to my
death
we have a lot in common yes
I saw that on your profile
look how about instead of like paying me
to have a baby or whatever
uh you just let me keep the money that I
make
[Music]
well thank you
they already they already like okay like
they take so much of it like I'm not
worried about like the getting pregnant
part it's the after it comes out where
do I put it yeah I don't have enough
room in my apartment and they're so
expensive like places to live yeah uh
and then you add a baby on top of it
which like that's like a luxury item it
really is like you got to be rich to
have a baby in the city exactly that's
why you build the New Towns he's trying
to give you the American dream you will
let me go move with my baby to the town
and then how do I come to work that's up
to you exactly
having it all to me would be
would baby and a job and it's like it's
getting more more and more difficult
even though it's supposed to be like
this modern idea you can have it all not
when you take all of my money I can't
yeah
[Applause]
of income tax is taxing the super rich
no the super rich don't make money off
income they make money off of assets
which I'd love to have some of those but
again they're taking all my money yes
yes all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else